previously on TV systems you're saying
that's not weird don't you think that's
plain damn weird yes sir
now we know they're among us bro now in
game narration front on game eration
zeros but we are going to show you their
faces because this is television and we
are dealing with that downy Hemsworth
Evans face kind of money down here and
monsters if this took place after the
Battle of New York people know Hulk is
one of the good guys right I guess Hulk
getting the short rift is gonna continue
in the MTU as well no you got a birthday
coming up in a couple of months who's
your favorite um okay DC you fans
strange shot composition with a crystal
clear background it's about to go down
called it I need you to stay here with
money
okay people might be sudden convenient
relationship with Bernie the hot dog
vendor is sudden inconvenient why call
nine on one when you can record a tragic
event on your smartphone hold up this
fool is it recording anything worth
watching on a flip phone from the 90s in
case you can be used it with Paris
Nebraska how exactly was he holding this
glass that he left every full
fingerprint consecutively around it
pulling a handprint from a hot cup of
cocoa I can get behind but nobody fists
a flute you know you're watching in
network TV show when a man chooses to
defend himself with a drawer instead of
a knife cool even when the MCU is shrunk
down for the telly it cuts the action so
badly I can't tell the ass-whoopin from
the throwing elbows okay this is
straight-up double homicide right are we
seriously rooting for this [ __ ] guy
what does shield stand for I did you ask
I've always wanted that spelled out for
me strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division okay
now I can immediately forget it and go
back to making my own answer up speak
happiness into every Lemon Drop means
someone really wanted our initials to
spell out shield agent jawline would be
excellent at TV since I haven't seen a
Maria Hill citing this inconsequential
since the conveniently arranged parade
of mourning an end game someone's job at
shield is to create these secure cases
with perfectly shaped inserts man that
person has borders to combat the mundane
slicing a protective foam these guys
insert tiny adorable lights to keep the
darkness company a giant green monster a
costumed hero from the 40s and a God
well five minutes into this thing and
it's already blatantly Avenger
referenced us three times I get that
it's fun and take place in the MCU but
all you're really doing is making me
want to watch the movies instead I'm
clearance level six I know that Agent
Coulson was killed in action welcome to
level seven sorry that corner was really
dark and I couldn't help myself
I love Agent Coulson you love Agent
Coulson we all can love Agent Coulson
which is why his death in the Avengers
was so meaningful bringing him back no
matter how
explain it away as an insult I'd say ten
sins worth of an insult although seeing
cap in the gang reunite with him in the
next movie is going to be awesome
can't wait for that to happen the shield
tech is advanced in every way except how
to abbreviate the month of April do they
know the Avengers The Fury claiming
they're not level seven they're not show
has a hard enough time beating around
the bush as to why these missions would
employ shield agents instead of actual
superheroes then they try and make us
believe that Iron Man and Captain
America don't have the same clearances
think how I Met Your Mother and the new
adventures of old Christine that's so
much bull my book detector just exploded
into a million Infinity stones cut out
of the ICU fury stuck me in a grass
Shack in Tahiti they spend the first
minute of the scene X positioning the
resurrection of Coulson then in the next
two minutes X positioning was set up for
the TV series for first episodes can we
trade out the title pilot for giant
exposition dump seemed more accurate in
most cases how are they getting this
stuff before us same way they cracked
our RSA implementation their good Lord
asks a good question and Coulson answers
with a smartass quip which in know
answers the question but still gives the
impression to the audience that it's
been covered this is gonna happen a lot
isn't it espionage to give you the
highest marks since Romanoff I swear
it's like the show's one big Captain
America I understood that reference meme
oh look a Google glass prototype poor
sucker drew the short end of the shield
stick to be stuck in that headgear that
Simmons is not cleared for combat
Shepard book not that I don't love
Firefly but Joss Whedon's pension for
winks and nudges has put this show at
around 90% Easter Egg quotient we
haven't seen EEE levels this high since
the great Pixar Wars of 1827 it doesn't
know you never know and neither can the
audience for a while which is why we're
being all vague and stuff character is
conveniently watching a news cast about
themselves in a crowded bar or
restaurant and the TV volume is somehow
turned all the way up so they can hear
it cliche I'm Skye and you're the hooded
hero fYI the hooded hero was my nickname
for my college girlfriends I'm not like
a groupie stalker type in the show
there's plenty of problems but Chloe
Bennet is not one of them the cute girl
from the hospital is dying to thank you
and possibly thank you we got [ __ ]
jokes y'all the clip of you restaurant
has had the most hit since the puppy
with vertigo and you can't even find a
job
who knew Ralph breaks the internet got
its money-making scheme from the pilot
of agents of shield
power comes a ton of weird crap hey
that's a Sony property reference
Whedon's lusts for references knows no
bounds also this whole conversation
which she started by insisting they keep
their voices down has migrated to the
middle of the restaurant in a very not
keeping your voice down soared away live
in a van by choice but it's always in
the alley around the corner free Wi-Fi
well good thing Mike chooses to have his
coffee right behind Sky's mobile office
then she bumped into him a moment ago
and swiped his driver's license not his
wallet just his license how also look at
Michael's penmanship I'm sinning this
just because I'm jealous no bounds I
tells ya Fitzsimmons
these two are super cute together but it
couldn't be more obvious that they will
be the will they or won't they couple of
the show at least we know they won't
drag that relationship out to the point
that it drives 85% of the plot the
entire series right don't touch Lola is
she choked do you want a sexual
harassment lawsuit because this is how
you get a sexual harassment lawsuit
people tend to confuse the words new and
improved you should know that you're at
Disney property nothing can stop us in
the cool bit Mambo
why wouldn't sky lock the door of her
van what is centipede well basically you
take the first person and so their lips
to the second person's oh wait did you
mean the video game from the Indies she
might as well be one of those sweaty
cosplay girls crowding around stark
tower that's cos placed I'm glad I'm not
the only one who has trouble matching my
base to my fleshy skin tone this is QNB
t16 but once out of the convenient
spotlight its dr katie 17 which is an
entirely less interesting liquid you'll
have a nice little map the black suits
the chrome gun the interrogation in the
secret but vaguely futuristic holding
cell this couldn't be more men in black
unless Will Smith jumped into the room
and somehow worked strategic homeland
intervention enforcement and logistics
into a rap over the credits employees
could not identify the attacker hard to
believe a factory full of people with
access to a clear video of the attack
wouldn't remember a recently fired
ex-coworker what have you got Michael
Peterson isn't this all information that
could have been figured out just through
the news footage doesn't she'll have
some fancy face database they could scan
he was on the news attacking the place
he used to work this doesn't seem
difficult well the man is angry the
other Twitter the encryptions coupled to
the GPS
get my van back to that alley and then
I'm in business so anyone who uses your
equipment in the place they found you
has full access and you don't have the
ability to use any of your stuff except
in one specific back alley well that's
just poor hackery disaster
no it's an origin story and a shoe is
Shama lining so hard right now I'm a
little irritated I didn't see the signs
earlier I mean it's possible I could use
my sixth sense but I'm not unbreakable
like the glass that didn't even split
when I dropped it in my last visit to
see the lady in the water The Last
Airbender also since when the hospitals
have windows that open nice I'm no tech
expert but wouldn't shield be concerned
with communicating to a regular old cell
phone why not give her an encrypted
earbud upgrade before sharing secrets by
using motion estimation Bayesian
inference a beam splitter and a little
diffraction CD a mystery man PS right
just say yada yada okay it's shorter and
you can pretend it was a Seinfeld
reference we don't love it Mike
what are you doing what every character
does on this show they wait till the
most convenient moment to show up and
conveniently show up the show should
have entitled agents of entrances Wow
you wanted a bomb a conversation between
studio execs about Thor the dark world
somehow makes it into this episode
someone's hacking our secure channels
longitude and latitude Mike took Skye
she's telling us well based on what Fitz
just said there's no way Coulson can
figure that out
this feels a lot less like natural
detection and more like there's 10
minutes left in this episode so say some
gobbledygook to get us to the finish
until you and everyone in fun
maybe your son remember that little guy
you know what maybe not sort of becoming
an [ __ ] for someone desperately
wanting to exit you think she'd follow
the crowd to the door that is open
luckily for Mike this operative went to
the finest stormtrooper school of aiming
at things after you serve a little time
for putting a man in the ICU right
county high and this turns out to be a
heel shot instead of a head shot in the
scene that establishes that Ward and
Coulson have to recomm eunuch ation the
fact that he doesn't give Coulson a
heads-up I have the cure and I'm gonna
shoot it into his head is the dumbest
dumb to ever dumb it's dumb rod down my
dumb hole man this British Jennifer
Garner British Jennifer Garner so hard
that I have to expect her to start
launching into a Capital One commercial
right now for someone who lives in a van
down by the alley Skye has a very
extensive and expensive looking wardrobe
play a team but we're in a position to
do some good you'd be a great help but
shield is still a government agency if
you have a visible tattoo you can't join
the FBI but despite her past filled with
illegalities Skye is somehow qualified
to hunt down superhumans and terrorist
organizations because she's a good
hacker and witty and it's because she's
hot isn't it it's kind of cool that
there's a TV show that ties directly
into the MCU and will play off those
storylines for the rest of its TV
lifespan instead of devolving into a
barely connected semi serious parody of
itself glad that'll never happen
costumes bed much so tight what changed
everything's changing I was a teenage
pop star in Canada really doesn't know
does he when you get the box and you
give us geography lessons until then
this man goes to ET what are you after
world peace we are the United States
government we don't do that sort of
thing you stay high I'll go low when
they go low we go high get me back my
son they're not heroes because of what
they have that we don't
it's what they do with it that doesn't
make sense there's no way we can make it
to the airfield
ten minutes we're going we don't need
roads
[Music]